creator alex pina said that
this will be the most epic
season yet how do you feel about how the
story ended overall
it's all very true warlike and and um we
want to see what we've done we don't
really know uh we're not really aware of
how it's gonna look
scenes are very short probably in the
script but it takes weeks to film them
so we don't really get a feeling of how
they're going to look but we expected
the way we felt it is that everything
was war and very epic and i hope that's
the way people
perceive it and we hope
fans are very happy with it
listen to professor
hi lisbon
the storm water tank has been discovered
it's possible this is the last time i'll
speak to all of you well how was it to
say goodbye to your characters for now
how was that
we started the season uh filming the
season what it was going to be the last
and uh then we had the true ending and
and feelings of rose again and then you
know
we're saying goodbye but just step by
step this symbol is probably going to be
the true the true end of it all
we learned so much you know been so
close to our characters and in myself
with stockholm uh i've said goodbye in
peace i've worked very hard with that
character and now i just want to see
what people think of it and we have to
go on and keep on doing things
[Music]
with me you'll find authentic liberation
and if we ever have to pay a price for
it
do you think that this is truly the end
when it comes to your characters would
you like to bring them back in the
future
probably not for the moment it's better
to let them recipe they're getting old
fast
it's nice to think that you could always
go back to
um
to your character
uh you know if if the uh characters from
friends met again many years later why
not they call you
in some you know some years could be
great just like that but but you need to
know when to stop as well
[Music]